rusia unida ha vuelto a hacerse con la
victoria en las elecciones legislativas
rusas pero los primeros resultados
apuntan a un notable retroceso de unos
13 puntos el partido de putin se lleva
el 41% de los votos y acusa el desgaste
de la crisis económica los comunistas
que lideran la oposición tolerada por
las autoridades rusas avanzan respecto a
convocatorias pasadas y tienen el 23 por
ciento un subidón de 11 puntos los rusos
votan una lista de partidos y una lista
con diputados por cada circunscripción y
esa puede ser la baza de vladimir putin
para amortiguar el golpe en el
parlamento con el 13 por ciento
escrutado los ultranacionalistas siguen
siendo terceros y los cuartos una
sorpresa el partido gente nueva que ha
sido acusado de ser la última creación
del kremlin para dividir el voto del
descontento lograrían entrar en el
parlamento con un ajustado 7% pero en la
jornada de hoy la tercera de votaciones
ha habido muchas irregularidades
algunos observadores independientes como
la entidad galos han denunciado
numerosas violaciones del procedimiento
en muchos casos las papeletas se
almacenaban durán la noche en
recipientes sin sellar o en salas sin
videovigilancia